et maintenant voici sportès morgon et
son roman fait divers sanglant les
assassinats de son froid de valérie
subra
ça s'appelle la pas aux éditions du
seuil plus ou genou pire que tout
sportès envoie ses pairs à patres mais
lui même est ce qu'il sème en morgan
sportès bonsoir lorsqu'on publie au sol
son septième livre qui consacre un fait
divers qui a défrayé la chronique en
1984 c'est l'histoire d'un trio infernal
ses affaires valérie subra ces
techniques valérie subra d'abord eric
grosse une jeune fille de 18 ans
qui a fait quelques études
d'esthéticienne école d'esthétique mais
si vous allez d'ailleurs alors il
voulait être mannequin en fait non elle
rêvait d'être mannequin elle révèle sa
balle tomber dans ses clichés dans
lequel tombent toutes les jeunes filles
de ses finances par valérie avait des
complices les deux complices c'était qui
l'un laurent hattab tout est le fils
d'un très riche commerçant dans le
prêt-à-porter et l'autre jean rémi
sarraud j'ai assez bien connu
et j'ai vu en prison de dire et qui lui
était un garçon qui sortait de la sq on
peut appeler un zona avec soin sont
consacrés et sans koné comment tous les
trois ils se sont connus ils se sont
connus dans l'est dans les boîtes de
nuit
je voulais gagner beaucoup d'argent
ouais ils ont fait quoi alors programmée
alors si vous voir la véritable problème
que ce pour quoi j'ai tâté de ce fait
divers s'est pas seulement la spectra
pull qui existent se sont pris un aspect
crapuleux on a tué deux hommes où il
cette tentative de meurtre dix jours
hein quoi faut voir ce que ces dix jours
il fait un tennis demeure donc il ya eu
deux assassinés absolument atroce il
faut voir aussi l'aspect social c'est
dire que ces gens là en fin de compte
youtube pour rien et parce qu'ils
croient toujours qu'ils ont plein de
pognon chez les gens c'est ça qui savent
pas quelle époque des cartes de crédit
personnelle et qui s'élève mais cela
wheels of legends les commerçants
certains commerçants touchés lesquels il
ya une certaine l'économie au noir de
cette idée là qu'il avait pas ce que
vaut cette idée là qu'il avait la tête
qu'est ce que c'est exactement ce dont
elle raconte exact quoi bon c'est elle
un principe hyper classique c'est-à-dire
la fille drague dans les boîtes
le bonhomme lui laisse son nouveau
téléphone
un jour elle prend un rendez vous ils
vont chez lui elle va chez lui et est le
bois un pot avec lui et puis lui demanda
jus d'orange en général c'est repoussé
jus d'orange et donc sans surprise de
jus d'orange et un moment donné quand
monsieur tourner le dos elle va ouvrir
la porte et donner l'adresse peut pas
avec le code de la porte centrale va
ouvrir la porte et un moment donné les
deux garçons rentrée et tu mets ça va
pas tuer en plus mal c'est la deuxième
fois il n'arrive pas à le tuer le même
c'est terrible parce qu est ce qui est
de fous pas comme ces deux fois si vous
la faites à l'inconscience de ces trois
je sais ils sont complètement
inconscients et complètement immoraux si
vous voulez les héros de dc aussi comme
race une histoire qui font des
transgressions notion du bien du mal ils
savent qu'ils font le mal quand ils vont
tuer mais là ils savent pas c'est un
espèce de jeux d'enfants et parents mes
dents mais qui a débarqué et quelqu'un
débarque explorer parce que bon la façon
de tuer quand même assez souvent payés
le deuxième est têtu et bien présent et
plus personne ne sait où
oui enfin il ya une hésitation je veux
dire là ils ont hésité pendant
des heures et des heures deux derniers
meurtres quatre ou cinq heures jeudi
raconte la victime était les pieds
poings nus à tourner en rond et et à se
dire parce que si vous les sarraus avait
tué le premier et pour le 2ème sa remise
à l'autre c'est ton tour
c'est à toi de faire les peines lors la
peine ils ont eu tous les trois
perpétuité avec 18 ans incompressibles
pour les deux garçons et 16 ans
incompressibles pour valérie subra
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sortiront tous les
trois en l'an 2000 avant de travailler à
l'infini à globo figaro magazine j'ai
fait quelques piges devrait vraiment de
honte tu as travaillé dans les journaux
quand même beaucoup plus détective
france dimanche et l'actu pris ce goût
des non j'ai pas franchement j'ai
travaillé le détective c'est le premier
journal où j'ai travaillé c'était en
1973 parce que c'était une blague au
départ j'avais un ami
jeudi un ami je voudrais aussi
extraordinaire parce que l'esprit de
puissance sur réaliste et humoristique
la loi dans leurs appareils enquête
formidable et le style est très simple
par rapport à ce qu'on a pu te reprocher
de temps j'entends un peu un style un
peu gras ville comme ça un peu pataud
gens
c'est kotick dans d'autres bouquins
celui-là est très simple très direct là
c'est un travail avant tout de
journalisme un billet de reconstruction
le travail littéraire dans la
construction de livre se dire bon il
n'est ce n'est pas un récit linéaire
bête il ya des anticipations décollage
bac il ya un très gros travail de
construction quand tu dragues dans les
boîtes manente a peur quand je voyage je
vais souvent me mets à des témoins dont
donc qui était l'ami d'une des victimes
était parti à bangkok il me répondait ça
il était parti à bangkok il avait bon
samedi eux on aime bien s'amuser
il devait redire mais encore qu'il avait
ramenés dans un chambre de deux filles
mais cette fois il avait fermé la porte
à clé et il prend un verre et les fit
main puis s'écroule il se réveille que
le lendemain à 15 il se retourne et
affolé par tous il est fils était la
folle elle n'avait pas pu sortir
il avait caché la clé donc oui
maintenant les champs ça a changé
beaucoup de choses dans les réactions
des gens c'est vrai que c'est un peu une
aventure dans un mois sa plus le sida se
donne le cocooning
c'est ça je crois que le site assez fier
parce que la fouille à l'hérésie métier
je dis moi quand je vais dans un bar
à panama ou ailleurs bondir est toujours
un mauvais coup qui rôde
ouais et puis au fond ça fait partie de
ça fait aussi partie de plaisir alors
que morgan tout est souvent élevé contre
la république bananière des lettres
françaises contre le pourrissement de la
langue est encore de faire des ennemis
alors on va voir si tu peux préciser on
va faire une interview ajouté prêt à
brûler
facile alexandre jardin l'athée de la
tuque en plastique
latulippe est en place et bernard henri
lévy au pour moi se sont produites dans
cette actu elle compare la lessive été
lancé parce qu'aucune été lancées par
françoise verny comme comme alexandre
jardin c'est comme ça enfin comme c'est
donc qu'ils croient pas nous il ya aucun
talent dans ce nom c'est dire moi ce que
je juge les gens sur les cris veut dire
qu'on me montre des livres je vous donne
de l'élan du suivant un suivi d'air chez
solidaires il ya une netteté et un
marchand ils fabriquent des produits
les gens savent qu'ils fabriquent des
produits d'ailleurs je vous ces produits
sont pas très bien fait les américains
fabrique des besner beaucoup mieux ce
sit-in techniquement cela il honnête
bonhomme il fait de la soupe et tout le
monde sait qui fait de la soupe et enfin
de quoi je préfère le monde de l'argent
et du marché à la bureaucratie
quelle qu'elle soit je suis pas pour les
communautés ça y est la tvh en échec
mais pour entasser la république des
lettres fonctionne comme ils ne vont pas
si j'ai déjà il ya 40 personnes qui
squattent tous à présent leur fromage
ils ont leur fromage et le pain du
fromage est minuscule tendance et de
chiffre d'affaires de l'édition en
france le chiffre d'affaires de l'oréal
et l'oréal le chiffre d'affaires du de
la littérature là dessus doit être une
une médina faible pourcentage de son
chiffre de province est rien donc je
veux dire quand il ya quarante rats qui
squattent c'est tenir de fromage
il reste plus grand chose pour les
véritables artistes mais ça c'est le
côté froid c'est petit hexagone province
moi je préfère les marchands de soupe
aux états unis
modiano mondial l'ofce quelqu'un pour
lequel j'ai une certaine sympathie c'est
quelqu'un qui ne veut plus pas sonné
mais fois j'avoue que ces livres on m'a
jamais vraiment emballé par jean edern
hallier belge ne rien dire c'est un ami
je souhaite un j'ai fait un ami à qui il
a collé quelques points de suture a joué
ses cinq points de suture mais enfin
c'est amical c'est parce que c'est un
acte amoureux
je crois que d'un allié c'est un des
derniers poètes défoncées de du monde
littéraire français c'est quand même pas
mal venir les derniers avant à la
closerie des lilas il va rencontrer des
vingtaines les gens qui avaient du
talent okapi de la folie et qui quand il
buvait et buvez vraiment se dorer
vraiment la gueule qu'ils étaient
capables de se dépenser aujourd'hui n'ya
que des gens qui s'économise et ça c'est
la petite bourgeoisie dans toute son
horreur j'étais la petite bourgeoisie au
pouvoir qui est maintenant justement ce
économie c'est ça qui est épouvantable
les artistes et gens qui donnent jean
marc roberts
quand on est au seuil on attendra
d'arrêt des gens du sort c'est charmant
c'est vraiment pas ma tasse de thé
mcroberts d'ailleurs je crois que
j'arrive à des gens qui s'économise je
suis prêt oui oui oui je sais
je sais pas si je crois qu'ils seront
pour un écrivain en ce moment
actuellement le venetian pas philippe
soler philippe sollers
c'est un des derniers aussi c'est comme
janvier dernier c'est un homme qui
appartient encore à une génération où on
avait lu un peu saint-simon et on avait
lu tous les ans maintenant ça n'existe
plus il voulait dans l'édition
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui n'ont
même pas lu le 2 places c'est effarant
il ya des gens qui s'en vante il ya un
ex éditeur de jeux chez gallimard à
passer chez grasset face avant qui s'est
vanté dans l'événement du jeudi de
n'avoir pas pu lire toutes les love 2
pouces et ils s'en vont il disait je
n'ai pu lire que le temps retrouvé mais
ces graphes chez gallimard et c'est ça
qui est très grave
ça fait partie de notre culture quand on
est plombier on connaît la plomberie
quand on est éditeur grande maison
littéraire on ne peut pas ne pas avoir
le crous c'est impossible quand on est
plombier dassault s'est apaisée c'est
impossible leur dernier nom du rouge ou
morgan sportès
c'est le meilleur non je plaisante mais
je suis quelqu'un
quoique le problème le problème c'est
tragique c'est bon tu colles des clichés
sur les gens mais je suis quand même
quelqu'un dont je suis à mon sixième but
cas je travaille énormément et je veux
dire il est tragique que des gens parce
qu'ils font un calembour un jour qui
lance une flèche se fasse démolir ou se
fasse censuré parce que je l'étais pas
pour cp tease
alors qu'on n'en vient pas à l'essentiel
c'est le texte
franchement j'ai fait des pas des
polémiques en ville mac j'ai descendu à
mr duras est descendu cette amie de la
ligue
le plus récent est plein et a coûté cher
oui enfin je veux dire j'ai été
sanctionné pour nos huit ans plus tôt
connu aucune annonce même pas nos faux
pas mais il n'annonce même pas d'une
annonce même pas
mon livre ce qui est très grave c'était
à refaire tu ferais pareil la polémique
est l'âme existence
c'est un des plaisirs du monde
littéraire dire du mal des gens on vient
de faire et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus